like it's literal things like that like
i'm like you you don't understand the
oppression just like you were saying
before
you would and more than likely they
probably will never understand the
oppression
at all so i just i don't i don't
understand this notion of bitterness or
anger when they get
so mad when you tell them that they
can't do something oh you know why
it's because they've never been told
that they can't do anything
exactly and so that's why when when they
meet that type of uh friction they're
like oh wait you're telling me i can't
do something
i'm i'm privileged i can do whatever i
want no you can't
yeah and that's what it feels like and
you know i feel like anybody who is a
you know white american that's listening
to this it's not this is not a negative
conversation where i'm dogging on like
white americans i got
you know it's it's all good you know
it's just it's a frustration that people
feel
yeah it would be nice if it was
understood yeah
and communicated that way but like i
said when you when you have a
conversation somebody tells you how they
feel about something
and you're dismissive of it and you say
you're just being sensitive
when you don't even know what it's like
it's kind of like
then where does this conversation go
right because for me too like
and i also get a note of the extra work
white people too like
they annoy the [ __ ] out of me even more
they they piss me off even more they're
like yeah
it's like because they try to
you're not woke sorry i just i mean you
understand
history that's great you know and you
understand certain elements
uh social social interactions and stuff
but
some of them take it to the point to
where um
not all because i have some friends who
are
white and they're woke so i don't want
to blanket everybody but
some that i've met they
legit think that they're so woke
that they know the struggle yeah and
it's like
rachel dolezal thank you that's one of
them
because we don't you don't open a can of
worms
rachel literally thinks oh oh
i can be black that's why she tans her
skin she gets her hair braided whatever
black people can't become white that's
no choice
and there's this there's even a hashtag
you can see it on instagram there's
um some european white girls and even
some of them here
they're they've gotten so tanned that
they look like black girls
oh they're they look like black girls
they get their hair braided i kid you
not if you did not see
this one girl exposed them and it was
like trending for like a couple months
it was like three or four girls they
look black like i'd even know they
weren't black
until i saw a picture before and after
people want to be black
because they think it's trendy a lot of
the times the trends that's
that that's hip and happening in popular
culture came from black culture
they want to be black up until a certain
extent until they need to invest
until they need to get loans or until
they need to get that job or that
acceleration
being black is a trend but you don't
want to you they don't want to have all
of the discords
and the the challenges that come with
being black look
no shame to the kardashians but they got
black bodies
and everything that they do is is based
off of black culture but they're still
white
yeah they still have the privilege of
being well
there are many in but they have uh
eurocentric features
that kind of like they they're not going
to get the discrimination that
black people get and so it's just it's
this thing like people want to soak it
up
and and have this culture but they don't
want the things that come with it
rachel can to today she could stop
tanning and stop putting weave in her
head and she gonna look like a white
woman
and get all her privileges back yeah and
that's the weird video when i saw a
picture of what she looked like before
that [ __ ] looked like a puritan yeah
she looked she looked like she turned
butterfly
amish like i was like you were you were
purebred
yes you were like straight from the
waterfall like she's over here
making wool blankets and making her own
butter she got about five sheep
you know you know it you know i guess
like the one thing that i did feel bad
about for her was
was how bullied her kids were yes
you know that's kind of funny because
her kids are mixed race yeah her kids
are mixed race kids and they they kind
of feel the brunt of like her mom's
choices which which sucks
you know yeah and i wish like they would
just leave those kids [ __ ] alone yeah
i i
i don't like when people bully kids at
all yeah um at all like leave the kids
out of it
i think that's what people i guess like
for me like i'm not a i don't like that
word cultural appropriation because it's
been
used so much it kind of lost all this
meaning but that's cultural
appropriation really means like
picking and choosing when you get to
have the benefits but you don't take all
the negative and all the all the stuff
that comes along with it and
i think that's definitively what
cultural appropriation is right yeah
it's like you can say um like for
example
i guess like a hot trend in modeling
there's this girl that i met through
like on instagram she's like she's a
really dope girl
she's a model friend of my friend darian
and she's kind of upset about this trend
where these models are doing this
they're making their eyes slander i
didn't know that
they'll do this they'll cover their face
half um
and they'll pull their eyes back and
it's like a trend right now like doing
this and
yeah it's like is it like with the
picture or like they actually putting
their hands
like the pictures like a modeling photo
to make like like asian asian eyes you
know and it's like a
it's like a trend right now and so if
asian people don't understand what it
feels like
you know that's why people had a i guess
like a certain i mean it was kind of
extreme like the whole dreads thing when
they saw a white person with dreads
uh some people took that really extreme
but i cannot kind of understand why it
felt that way because it was like
so i used to get made fun of for that
hair
people said it was dirty people said it
was raggedy as [ __ ] but now you put it
on and now you're this woke ass person
and you're a trendsetter
so what the [ __ ] i don't get that [ __ ]
you know so it's the same thing with
these asian eyes when they people people
see this exactly
so maybe that's what it feels like yeah
that what they do
this particular race does this with
everybody they do what the black folks
they do with the asian folks they do it
with
hispanic folks they do with the indians
yeah i mean
look at redskins we still haven't
changed the name of the football team
yeah you know so it's it's like i don't
it frustrates me so badly um because
it's like they don't care like you can
bring it up as much as you want and
they'll try to act like oh there's we're
we're hearing you
but you haven't done anything yeah and i
don't i don't know where that culture
came from where
it's like okay like for instance i was
so pissed off when kim kardashian posted
her her shade i do braids that she had
and she was like oh
it's by um what was it what's the girl's
name billy
or i forgot some white model from like
the 70s
i said that girl that came from africa
okay the zulu people were doing their
hair like that
and that's the hairstyle she's like oh
you know i love i think it's not
bojangles lord i'm thinking about a
certain way
but yeah like you know about that fried
chicken joint in the [ __ ] yeah
like you know just like they've been
doing this for age bo derek here there
you go
um you know they've been doing this for
ages with
with menstrual menstrual c like you know
doing the blackface or like when they
wanted to portray indians in movies they
would all like do like a really tan
brown face and feathers in their hair i
just like it pisses me off when i see
stuff like
i haven't seen that yet so i know i will
be infuriated by that because just like
you're doing this what what are you
doing that for
yeah i don't know what's the point just
like with your lip injections y'all were
making fun of us ooh
big lip in the big booty and it's hot
isn't that so [ __ ] wild
remember like like people used to make
fun of that [ __ ] jokes like oh my god
look at her [ __ ] fat ass like it was
a bad thing
and now it's a hot it's [ __ ] hard
right now like oh my gosh
i got my lips done jay-z lips like what
the heck
this is trendy now yeah you know and
that's what pisses me off man it's just
i can't it's it's so it's a weird
feeling man because it's like everything
that you were made fun of before
is now with a hot thing and now you go
from like
you know people sometimes see it as this
it's like well aren't you happy because
now like you're the it thing but it's
like no because now it's like i feel
like an object like i feel
now i get to say now i have the
privilege to be like objectified or
something
like it's hard to explain to somebody
you know and i don't want to sound like
somebody that's complaining about this
stuff but as i get older i do think
about this stuff like things just don't
roll off my shoulders like it used to
yeah but the thing is is i'm not gonna
feel happy
yeah because i'm not benefiting from
this they're benefiting from it
they can have the hairstyle and then go
back to their normal lives
and they're fine yeah but this is who i
am my hair is kinky
yeah okay but if you're telling me to
press i remember i was
trying out right after i got out of grad
school at sc
i was trying out for like i wanted to do
tv reporting instead of
print reporting yeah and so this lady
told me straight up
there's a a really big brand that does
like placement
and styling for on-air reporters
and so you know i showed her like my
portfolio and my real and everything she
was like
well if you want to be on tv you're
going to need to lose like 80 pounds
yes and um you need to do something with
your hair
yeah i was like like what with my hair
like you know i could put in a bun
she was like no you're gonna have to
straighten that and
in my mind i'm like what's the problem
with my natural hair
yeah literally and so it that blew me
away
because i've never experienced that kind
of professional
like prejudice or that professional like
racism and so i went to the bathroom and
i bawled my eyes out
yeah and so there was a reporter that
was hearing me crying and she was like
girl do what you need to do
she was like you know the game has not
changed for years and years if you need
to wear a wig for now
and then later on down the line you know
you can wear your natural hair but just
do what you need to do and i
that even hearing her that even made me
mad
because she she because she's eventually
yeah she gave in and this is a
well-known reporter and i'm just like i
get it
but when are we gonna stop like for real
y'all are hating on me because my hair
is kinky
yeah and y'all telling me that i now i
have to
subject myself to your american
standards
yo people didn't even understand this
concept i actually wrote a sketch for
khalif called let me touch a fro
oh remember that yes i remember
so people don't people thought it was
hilarious but that was
i wrote that sketch for khalif because i
i always heard that [ __ ] growing up
and i always say this i always shout out
my hometown sacramento because of how
culturally diverse it is because a lot
of the stuff that people
talk about i wouldn't be on their way
like they didn't understand what was the
problem why can't i ask to touch his
hair because he's not your [ __ ] pet
that's why i'm it's just it's hair it's
his hair
like even like so mary like i love meryl
to death but she didn't grow up around a
single [ __ ] black person
so for her you know she's just you know
for khalifa because he's my he's like
one of my closest friends she's like
she's like like you mind if i touch your
hair you know and i told her i was like
it's okay because khalif were close like
that but in general you shouldn't do
that
like it's not something that you should
do and for um she's she's
a [ __ ] intelligent woman so she's
like oh i understand she gets it you
know but for her
it's it's just at least she asked at
least she [ __ ] had some people just
go up and touch it because i smacked
this woman's hand
one day yes i sure did last year i had a
afro it wasn't my hair but you know
it was a weave but she it was really bad
it's your [ __ ] hair yeah i bought it
so it was real big
this woman like i'm helping her like you
know i'm at work
yeah okay all of a sudden i feel
something in my head
she put her hand in my head i said
excuse me
no you don't do that oh i just wanted to
i was like would you like it if i
started doing this to you and i started
putting my hands all up in her hair like
oh my gosh your hair's so straight
yeah all this other stuff i should've oh
wow oh yeah you don't do that
i'm not your pet this is my hair you
don't touch me without asking
exactly and it's so weird how even at
that moment
when you said excuse me what are you
doing she thought that oh
i was just touching your hair was an
acceptable response and then she thought
oh it's going to be cool if i say i was
just touching your hair
it's like if i was chilling right and
then uh some some lady or dude came up
and touched mario's hair because they
thought it was so silky i would grab
that [ __ ] and i'd snap his
[ __ ] head so you don't [ __ ] touch
it without asking exactly
you know it's the same concept that's
what i'm saying that that's like this
huge disconnect and i've never been able
to understand that
because well number one my parents owned
a beauty supply store so i grew up
around black women
20. i'm still waiting on my hair yo let
me know what you want because my parents
might return a couple years
i need a 24 inch 24 inch what i don't
know i got to think about peruvian
you want that indian remy hair yeah
you're trying to get that silky silky
[ __ ]
i'm trying to
your hair got [ __ ] expensive as [ __ ]
yes so like
i'm gonna do some hair talk real quick
but um
so when i was working at my parents
store i used to help them run it and
[ __ ] but i remember that was just out of
nowhere the hair prices skyrocket
and you know what [ __ ] happened
[ __ ] white people started to
understand
like yo i don't have to do my actual
hair and grow it out i could just put in
clips and extensions on yeah and then
the price went
boom we used to have like the 7.99 packs
of 6.99
and it was all human hair it wasn't
human hair blend it was the real thing
human hair and it wasn't as good as some
of the other stuff but if people wanted
something real quick that was cheap
because by the way when you buy hair
that's not already the cost the process
cost
more so you got to buy this expensive
ass hair got to buy the needle to do the
threading yeah exactly
and so like i just remembered the price
of skyrocketing and everybody
they were mad at us like oh you're
trying to [ __ ] profit it's like no i
don't think you realize
this [ __ ] got hella expensive yep like
our our seven dollar packs became 15
packs yeah our 10 packs were now 25
bucks and it was just the same margins
for us but we just had to up it up and
people didn't get it they thought we
were trying to like
oh like oh you [ __ ] trying to profit
off no i was like no mother we're trying
to live yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] i got this [ __ ]
like thrift store clothesline what'd you
think i'm balling the [ __ ]
i got this dashiki i got from somebody
else
it's the same thing with wig culture too
because now
everybody's wearing wigs yo i'm telling
you real quick when beyonce i forgot
what performance it was but she had that
lace front wig
lace front wigs blew the [ __ ] up
and that's all everybody wanted from us
because back in the day
it was just pro style gel and a [ __ ]
drawstring ponytail
full closure
child i missed ponytail days it was easy
back then
it sure was like you don't have to do
all this oh my gosh i need to put
you know the glue right here and lay the
lace down put down the baby
like it's just too much nowadays that's
what the lace front did it gave it gave
the baby hair so it looked really
like it came from your scalp even though
we all know that some lace
well we know that's the lace they ain't
come from your scalp dude that [ __ ]
would be so funny cause like i remember
uh
like i would hear people like
specifically when i was in school
because you know people don't expect
this like korean asian kid to have grown
up around black women
with black women hair problems and
everything and i'll just hear some [ __ ]
that used to crack me up be like damn
this girl every day she gets her hair
done she doesn't hit she's like she
didn't get that hair done she
snapped that [ __ ] on real quick
it took two seconds no cause i changed